one word to describe the talent you've
seen so far for season two exponentially
that sounds exponential yes my word is
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious i'm
lauren zima here in Hollywood as a night
of auditions winds down for American
Idol we talked to the judges right after
they'd watched hours of singers they
were in love slap-happy we were catching
the end of auditions in there and how
tired are you guys are you alright let's
get a little crispy at the end of the
day but but the amazing thing is when
somebody truly talented walks in we get
I mean it you know wow yeah it energizes
us right right I mean that's our version
of scrolling we're like okay well that's
great you're nice and then someone got
someone actually start seeing that's
really good and really but we so yeah I
mean we do our concentration of ABS and
flows a little bit but but you know they
got to give us something wake you up to
get our attention and that's what and by
the way I'm loving this cuz it's like
the show's happening again getting
another season and you guys are still
razzing each other a little bit how is
this relationship I'm you know we're I
think we have the same sense of humor a
little bit
Luke reminds me of my dad in a way
because my father's from Memphis he's
real southern he's real jokes her pranks
are full thick accent and that's how my
dad and I bond is just we just joke on
the rest of the family we are pulling
pranks 24/7 well was the joke earlier I
want to get it straight that you were
told your body is not as good as Orlando
Bloom's can you weigh in I mean yeah yes
- no I've never seen him in a bathing
suit yeah it's not Orlando I saw Orlando
through his his chic wool coat in New
York
City last week and I'm like yeah I think
if you put your if you put your this
together would look like a plain bagel
to Orlando on Instagram the man works
out he looks good
I mean he's always trying to get me a
hike yoga eat vegan oh my god it is like
I'll hike to Taco Bell with you
I sure will Crunchwrap supreme extra
money extra onions he tries to keep you
in line a little bit well you know
there's a balance I think when you know
you when you're attracted to someone
it's kind of opposites attract and so
I'm looking for that balance and maybe
he's looking for that I you know
multitask I'm such a multitasker are you
blah blah blah but you know what we're
really excited because this season
American Idol this season of American
Idol people are taking us seriously and
with that a lot of amazing talent like
talent that I think should already be
signed or about record deals or they are
already artists or they probably have
tons of YouTube streams or a follow up
there
they're showing up for us and using us
as a as a platform to launch like will
will have these contestants walk in and
we're like what have you been doing like
how where have you been we had one girl
that um the girl that did Norah Jones
and she wanted to be a dental hygiene
folson you know scrape and tartar and it
could be the next American Idol you know
so that's what that's what makes you get
really excited about being on this show
you